san francisco mayor london breed was
just caught violating her own mask
mandate while she was dancing at one of
the city's jazz clubs now the the
incident was caught on tape so mayor
breed cannot deny that she was
disobeying the mask mandate instead
she's making excuses she's justifying it
you see what you don't understand
is it's totally fine for mayor breed to
ditch her mask while all you peasants
have to wear your masks because mayor
breed
was feeling the spirit my drink was
sitting at the table
i got up and started dancing because i
was feeling the spirit
and i wasn't thinking about a mask i was
thinking about having a good time
and in the process i was following the
health orders go out and enjoy yourself
make sure you are vaccinated because of
the requirements
but don't feel as though you have to be
micromanaged about mass wearing like we
don't need the fun police to come in and
try and micromanage and tell us what we
should or shouldn't be doing we know
what we need to do to protect themselves
ourselves and let me tell you
when the spirit moves you because you
are watching history in the making bay
area royalty perform i don't know about
you but i'm not going to turn around and
look for where my mask is
mayor breed i totally agree we do not
need the fun police now
you are the fun police i mean you you
are the chief law enforcement agent you
are the executive of san francisco so
you're making all these other people
wear it but but now look if you're
telling me that right now that law is
off the books that mask mandate is no
more if you are feeling the spirit well
that's fine by me because as a fellow
spirit feeler myself i
completely agree let's all ditch the
stupid masks i'm michael knowles this
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
you know
when i want to make sure that my health
is totally fine i don't just look to
these expert mandate power happy
politicians
i check out by optimizers if you're
having trouble falling asleep or staying
asleep
one of the best things you can possibly
do is to start getting enough magnesium
now before you run out the door hold on
hold on a second
you might be inclined to go run out the
door go find the first magnesium
supplement that you can do not do that
most of them that you'll find in the
store made with just the two
cheapest most synthetic forms of
magnesium they are not full spectrum
they will not fix your magnesium
deficiency or help you sleep better
there are actually seven unique forms of
magnesium you have to get all of them if
you want to experience its calming sleep
enhancing effects which is why i would
recommend magnesium breakthrough by by
optimizers you just take two capsules
before you go to bed you will be amazed
how much better you sleep and how much
more rested you feel when you wake up
for an exclusive offer right now
head on over to magbreakthrough.com
knowles use code knowles 10 to save 10
when you try magnesium breakthrough one
more thing for a limited time buy
optimizers is also giving away free
bottles of their best-selling products
p3om
and massimes with select purchases go to
magbreakthrough.com
knowles right now to get your exclusive
10 discount plus the chance to get more
than 50
worth of supplements for free if you're
feeling the spirit
lose that mask could not possibly agree
more if it turns out it's more than just
mayor breed who has been feeling the
spirit
the showbiz royalty of los angeles the
people who were attending the emmy
awards
also appeared to have been feeling the
spirit the other night because while
that county has a very strict mandate
back in place it's a mandate that i
actually fled last year and somehow it's
now back in place in la
the the showbiz people didn't wear their
masks so at
the emmys
you didn't see
any masks anywhere to be found you know
usually at these kind of glitzy events
you'll be able to peek that in the
background the staff the help the filth
are wearing their masks while the
wonderful beautiful aristocrats they
don't need to wear their masks but here
you just didn't really see a mask in
sight well why is that
the emmys have come out and made clear
that exceptions quote exceptions are
made for film television and music
productions since quote additional
safety modifications are made for such
events and so it's it's totally fine
for
the
showbiz stars not to wear the masks
you have to they don't you have to are
you getting it yet are you are you
seeing what's happening
as i have said from the beginning
the mask mandates are not about the
science and they're not really even
about public health they are about the
capricious wielding of power that grants
certain privileges to some people and
takes away those privileges from other
people i love
mayor breed's attitude in san francisco
oh come on we all know the masks are bs
come on we all know this is ridiculous
you're having a good time just go out
and have a good time you know what you
need to do to protect your health so
just do it exercise your prudence and
don't worry about the masks that that'd
be all well and good if she and all of
her other politician buddies were not
forcing people to wear them
someone tweeted this out yesterday i
forget who it was
would you know
what an oligarchy looked like if you saw
one
would you know i mean we we are told
that we live in a democracy we live in a
republic we live in this constitutional
order
would you know if that had morphed into
an oligarchy there is an ancient concept
and a cyclosis the cycle of regimes how
regimes can descend
in from a democracy into an oligarchy
say into a monarchy maybe back into
would you be able to tell when things
had shifted because one of the telltale
signs i think is that there would be one
set of rules a nice
free advantageous set of rules for a
small ruling elite and there would be a
completely different set of rules for
the rest of us
that i think is what
we are
seeing what about the
illegal aliens pouring over our border
you know we have a very porous border to
the south under joe biden it's reached
record levels of foreign nationals
pouring into this country
what's the rule for
them democrat elite
no masks so long as you're feeling the
spirit
rest of the country especially us
deplorable irredeemable mega supremacist
rate whatever people
you have to wear the mask what about the
foreign nationals who are pouring into
our country at the permission and really
encouragement of the biden
administration what
turns out i guess they're feeling the
spirit too because the people crossing
into our country are not wearing masks
there is no evidence that they're
vaccinated at all
so
i can't go into a bar in new york unless
i show proof of that i've had 7000
booster shots and have 10 masks on
but a guatemalan national can trot
across the border no big deal gensake
was asked about this and the white
house's official position is that you
don't need to worry about their masks
and you don't need to worry about their
vaccines
because you know they're probably not
going to stay
is somebody asking the foreign nationals
who are walking into del rio texas and
setting up camps on this side of the
border
for proof of vaccination or a negative
covenant test let me explain to you
again peter how our process works as
individuals as individuals come across
the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have
any symptoms if they have symptoms they
are the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time i don't think it's the
same thing it's not the same thing these
are individuals as we've noted and as
we've been discussed we are expelling
individuals based on title 42
specifically because of covid because we
want to prevent a scenario where large
numbers of people are gathering posing a
threat to the community and also to the
migrants themselves so those are the
policies that we put in place
in large part because again the cdc
continues to recommend title 42 be in
place given we're facing a global
pandemic
they're not intending to stay here for a
long period of time
does jen saki think that the illegal
aliens are just taking a nice vacation
in the united states they're they're
just taking a little weekend jaunt
yes you know juan got monday off too so
we're gonna be up for in texas for three
days and then we're gonna trot right
back across the rio grande and go back
to mexico is that what's going to happen
or are they going to stay here forever
and ever and ever and generation unto
generation unto generation i
suspect it would be
the latter
so right there is an
obvious lie illegal aliens are not just
coming
for a day or two they're they're coming
permanently that's that's the point
that's why you make the track
further then she says look peter you're
being unfair we are
well she doesn't say we're quarantining
people with symptoms she goes the
intention is to quarantine people with
symptoms so they're probably almost
certainly not even doing that but okay
at least the intention is there to
quarantine people with symptoms but hold
on
i was told that covid spreads because of
asymptomatic people
furthermore i was told that covid
spreads because of asymptomatic
vaccinated people that's why i need to
wear the mask the mask which i was told
is
exists to protect other people from my
germs
i was told that after i was told that
the masks don't work at all by dr fauci
but then i was told that the masks exist
not really to protect you
but to protect other people from your
germs even if you're asymptomatic even
if you're vaccinated why do people need
to wear the vaccines
on airplanes why do people need to wear
the vaccines
in their workplace why do people who are
vaccinated who show proof of their
vaccination have to wear the masks
why
because
it's not about
the rule
it's not about the principle it's not
about the virus or the microbes or
stopping the spread it's about the
people upon whom the rule is imposed
it's it's not about the little virus
it's about
the movie star the tv stars at the emmys
and it's about the illegal aliens that
the biden administration wants to flood
into the country because they believe it
will give democrats a permanent
electoral advantage
and it's about
you
and
the first two groups they can use their
prudence we can prioritize their hopes
and dreams they want to come into
america they want to win their gold
statues they want to feel the spirit and
dance before bay area royalty man that
was some good jazz you expect me to wear
a mask when i got that good jazz going
on
then they're going to lie to you like
the mayor of san francisco did and say
look i was i had my drink down i was
dancing without a mask i was following
health procedures you manifestly were
not following health procedures even
according to your own logic
and then they're going to tell you to do
whatever they say would you know an
oligarchy if you saw one
would you know good american meat if you
saw it i bet you would not that's why
you got to go check out our friends over
at good ranchers did you know that 80
percent of the grass-fed beef sold in
the united states is actually imported
from overseas sometimes they'll say it's
from a local farm it's from a local farm
in south america somewhere it's not from
one here which is why you got to check
out the good ranchers the good ranchers
are helping out the american rancher
they're helping out the american
consumer and they are giving you top
quality beef for unbelievable prices so
whatever you want they have they have
actually more than beef they've got
better than organic chicken but me i'm a
little more of a beef guy they got the
t-bones they got the fillets they got
the strips they have to my mind
basically the best burgers out there
they're gourmet delicious burgers that
are juicy that i've had within the past
few weeks go check them out right now
you get steakhouse quality at a price
every family can afford right now if you
go to goodranchers.com
you can save 20 bucks or better yet you
can subscribe and save on each box of
mouth-watering american meats that will
show up right on schedule to your door
so right now 20 bucks off free express
shipping if you go to
goodranchers.com or use code knowles at
checkout 20 bucks off in free express
shipping at goodranchers.com
knowles
you are hearing about a lot of different
stories in the news there's a story
about a young woman who is a travel
blogger who went missing and now i think
has turned up dead and then the
boyfriend sort of went missing too and
it's one of the you know it's a very sad
story but it's a it's
just kind of a personal interest story
it's not a i don't think it means
anything for our broader politics and
the media are
totally focusing on this story this is
this is where you've got to put your
attention
meanwhile
we have an historic flood of foreign
nationals
across our southern border
you're not supposed to look at that
ignore that focus on a youtuber and this
you know very sad kind of personal
romantic crime story
but don't look at the bigger political
issue which is that we've already taken
i think over 1.2 million illegal aliens
into this country this year and we're
going to take way more than that
okay we're it's it's only heating up
right now
and we are we are being told that the
the
criminals in this situation
are the americans
are the handful of americans who are in
any way attempting to enforce the law
there was a blue check lib on twitter
sawyer hackett he is the executive
director of julian castro's people first
future i julian castro you will recall
ran for president
on the
unexpected platform of allowing men to
have abortions you might remember he
said we need abortion we need
reproductive justice
for trans women
say
trans woman is a trans woman doesn't
have a uterus i don't think you okay i
guess i i'm for abortions for trans
women too they can have as many
abortions as they want
so julian castro did not make it very
long in the race now i guess this guy
sawyer hackett is running his new
organization
sarah hackett sees a picture of just a
handful of
border patrol on horseback who are
trying in any way to stop the flow of
illegal immigrants
and he tweets this quote border patrol
is mounted on horseback rounding up
haitian refugees with whips
this is unfathomable cruelty toward
people fleeing disaster and political
ruin this administration must stop this
so i saw that tweet and i said you know
i i'm not saying i'm a zillionaire okay
i'm not saying i'm a man of
extraordinary means but i would bet
every penny to my name that the border
patrol is not whipping
haitian
migrants
i would i would bet that and then i
looked and i saw no they're right
they're not whipping haitian migrants
they're holding the reins of their
horses
but
the left is so
culturally illiterate
that they don't they don't know that
they're not culturally illiterate i bet
they know a lot more about the emmys
than i do i bet they know a lot more
about those oscar-nominated movies that
three people saw than i do but they
don't know
the basic elements of horseback riding
they do this with guns all the time
they'll say he he had a semi-fully
automatic
assault rifle with uh with a 70
ammo clip and it was a super duper
assault and you think you don't know
anything about
weapons or what automatic means or
semi-automatic and and these are the
people who are attempting to regulate
your weapons
the same thing here
not only do you not know anything about
immigration enforcement not only do you
not know anything about law enforcement
generally you don't even know about
horses you don't even know you know
another thing that they're riding on
so they're not a border patrol i mean
they're doing what they can but their
their hands are tied not by whips or
reigns but by
the political chains of the biden
administration and so they've just got
to let these these immigrants come over
a huge number of them are haitian which
is kind of weird because haiti is a
little island right haiti is not
haiti is not part of mexico so how'd
they get over here i don't know but they
make it to mexico and they're crossing
over into the united states
and we
we have to think well you know no you
have to you go to haiti or you go to
some other country but you can't not
everyone in the entire world can come
into the united states that won't be
good for anybody it won't be good for
america it won't be good for our rule of
law and it won't be good for the people
because if everyone floods here then our
country does isn't a country anymore the
place they're fleeing to will cease to
exist
if we just completely open up our
borders
ilhan omar has a different point of view
ilhano more radical left-wing
congressman
she came out and said
not only should we allow the haitian
migrants to come in
we owe it to them
i've also heard people say
haitians might many of the asians who
are at our border might not have
actual grounds to seek asylum these are
people who have experienced a natural
disaster
which allows for people who experience
that to seek asylum they've also
experienced
political violence
political and evil they have experienced
a crisis after crisis
we have also contributed to that
generations
of haitians have experienced american
policy that has contributed to their
starvation to the criminalization that
they are dealing with and to the
inhumane policies that continue
to destroy the lives of haitians so not
only do we owe
haitians the
uh
the right thing of allowing them um to
to seek asylum here but we also owe them
uh the the kind of policies that would
allow for them to dictate the ways in
which they want to run their country
can anyone listening out there translate
that into english for me because i have
no idea what ilhan omar just said people
used to get on trump they used to attack
trump because trump would speak in vague
terms because maybe he he wasn't totally
caught up on all the details of
everything look we're gonna do something
that is really really positive okay and
we are we don't want to do anything that
is bad for a man we're going to do only
good things okay and you say okay well
you're speaking these really broad terms
ilhan omar is speaking in precisely the
same degree of vagueness
she goes
haitians have experienced political
violence political upheaval crisis after
crisis that's true haiti is basically a
cursed country that has had
problems from the very beginning that's
certainly true
largely political problems largely
problems of the haitians own making but
also natural disasters and earthquakes
and things like that
we have also contributed to that ilhan
omar says
generations of haitians have experienced
american policy that have contributed to
their starvation to the criminalization
that they are dealing with whatever that
means
to the inhumane policies that continue
to destroy the lives of haitians what
what policies
okay so your your claim ilhan omar is
america basically it's america's fault
everything is america's fault it's all
our fault here
so
what is it what did we do
did we give them a ton of aid after all
of their natural disasters
did we
let a lot of them in every single year
into our country did what did we what
did we do that was so bad
can you specify what what contributed to
their starvation all the money that we
give them and all the food or what can
what what about the criminalization what
i don't even know what that means the
inhumane policies you mean letting them
come into our country illegally i i
agree that is inhu it's inhumane to
americans it's not inhumane
in a way i guess it is inhumane to the
haitians because if you cross that
border you're dealing with a ton of
criminals and you're putting yourself in
a very bad situation which is why
encouraging those kinds of policies is
so
awful
we owe it to haitians to do the right
thing to let them seek asylum here and
we owe them the kinds of policies that
would allow for them to dictate the ways
in which they they want to run their
country
what
what do we owe them i don't think we owe
them anything frankly
i think we owe solidarity to our fellow
man and we ought to be very generous as
we always are and we ought to love the
lord our god above all things and love
our neighbor as our self
that does not mean
destroy your own country that will not
help our neighbor as ourselves we're not
helping ourselves then in any way we
don't have any regard for ourselves
we're actually annihilating the country
by getting rid of our borders so i don't
think that will help our neighbors at
all
they've experienced crisis
after crisis we've contributed we've
done it's our fault
well then why the hell are they coming
here oh man if this if we're if truly we
are the great satan we are the worst
country ever we are responsible for all
the problems that they are fleeing why
would they come here
this place sounds terrible you know the
most humane thing to do i think the most
generous thing to do would be to say no
not a single haitian gets in because we
don't want to be any more inhumane and
cruel to you but she doesn't believe
this i mean no nobody believes this this
is madness
we talked yesterday in the show about
how things are not always as they seem
one of the great advantages of the trump
era of politics and now in the post
post-trump era i guess maybe we're in
the pre-trump era again depending on
what happens in 2024 but one of the
great advantages of it is we're seeing
the difference between how things appear
and how things really are would you know
an oligarchy if you saw one
how how our government appears is that
it's our democracy and you know are the
the people's house and that's why the
attack of january 6 was the worst event
in american history but the reality is
i don't know that the people have a
whole lot of say in their government
i don't know that
the system of government that we were
taught in civics class and schoolhouse
rock and i'm a bill on capitol hill i'm
not sure that's the way we're really run
and furthermore we're told that the
vaccines are the big issue and the
people who are not wearing the masks not
taking the vaccine not going along with
the health measures we're told it's all
these white male terrible christian
republican trump supporters
well it's not i don't think it is i
think it's the mayor of san francisco
and i think there's another story out of
new york of three black women who were
so angry at the mandates that they
actually attacked the hostess at a
popular restaurant
you know
it's very very important
very very important when we think about
how we're going to run our country how
we're going to protect our rights
to protect the right to life which is
why you got to check out 40 days for
life it's been a tough news cycle the
past
few weeks months
almost years and so when you get some
good news you should take it namely this
pro-life law in texas this is the best
news for the pro-life movement
maybe since roe versus wade
you're going to see this come up a lot
in conversation at parties with your
family you're going to want to know all
of the arguments because the left is
losing their minds over this and they
are demagoguing this issue and they're
trying to fight it tooth and nail what i
would recommend is checking out a new
book
it's a new book from 40 days for life
it's called what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion it's a really easy read for
individuals who are looking to defend
life and convert hearts okay a lot has
changed since roe v wade in 1973 what to
say when equips readers with the proven
approaches to dismantling the
pro-abortion agenda okay the 40 days for
life members have already been able to
convert the hearts of 221 abortion
workers how incredible is that so learn
what to say what not to say the book is
called what to say when the complete new
guide to discussing abortion how to
change minds and convert hearts in a
brave new world get free shipping and 21
off assigned hardback at 40 days for
life
dot com slash
what to say when
also head on over to dailywire.com right
now speaking of these vaccine mandates
you know joe biden through the
administrative agencies through all
these extra constitutional provisions is
going to try to
force all of you to take the fouchyache
by forcing your employers
to force you to do it right we're not
going to comply with that we're just
we're just not sorry see you buddy
so we we may have to go to court we'll
find out how it goes if you want to help
us out in that fight if you want to
stand with us while we stand with you
head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply at
checkout you will get 25 off enough is
enough please stand with us please stay
with the daily wire more importantly
stand with all of the americans that we
we do not think should have to go along
with joe biden's preposterous
extra constitutional edict we'll be
right back with a lot more
three people just attacked a hostess at
a very famous italian restaurant in new
york on the upper west side because the
hostess asked to see their vaccine cards
asked for proof of vaccination i don't
think the restaurant wanted to do this
i've been to this restaurant on a number
of occasions and i think they're good
good old restaurant carmines but the
city is forcing them to and so the
hostess was complying with the stupid
city ordinance and these three people
beat up the hostess now
if you watch cnn
if you read the new york times you know
who were these three people they were
three
white
male republican probably christian
trump supporters
anti-vaxxer
murderers
who wouldn't
show the vaccine proof so they don't get
their bowl of spaghetti right
so what are their names uh keita
nikingei
rankin 44 years old tiyani kashay rankin
21
and sally richelle lewis 49.
they were arrested and charged with
assault and criminal mischief they don't
so those
names gosh i don't want to get in
trouble i don't want to stereotype or
they don't
they sound a little more ethnically
ambiguous than we were told about the
unba the the white male trump supporters
right
uh they don't sound male that's for sure
uh no it turns out there are three
tourists three black women who were
visiting
new york
they show up to the restaurant they
don't want to go along with the mandate
i think these women are from texas where
you don't need to show proof of your
fauciachi so they must have been very
surprised
now a lawyer for the women this is where
the story gets complicated
now a story a lawyer for the women is
saying that the hostess used a racial
slur i don't believe that i've been to
carmine's i just don't think that's true
there's so many hoaxes that go on i
write about a lot of those hoaxes race
hoaxes in uh my book speechless which
you can get the the worst thing you can
be called in america is is a racist the
worst offense you can possibly commit is
to utter the n-word and so the
the lawyer is saying that i don't think
there's any evidence that the restaurant
is vigorously denying that now
blm is showing up and saying they're
going to protest not just carmines for
the hostesses alleged behavior that i am
fairly certain did not take place
but they're also going to protest the
city's vaccine mandate which they say is
is a way to keep black people out of
places
because
contrary to cnn reports
black people disproportionately are not
getting the vaccine and so they want to
blame everything on white males because
white males are the the worst creatures
in the history of the world and
everything they do is terrible
but they because they're trying to blame
this they're trying to discourage this
behavior
they
they don't want to acknowledge that a
lot of black people are engaging the
same kind of behavior namely not wanting
to get the focus right away so this is a
very politically this might be the most
complex political story of all time
because first part of the story three
women refuse to go along with a vaccine
mandate love that love that refused to
show their papers at the restaurant love
that man that's great kudos to them
next part of the story they beat up the
hostess well that's bad we don't like
that don't beat up the hostess okay
especially at carmine's because it's a
nice restaurant
hate that next part of the story they're
accusing this hostess now of using a
racial slur almost certainly didn't
happen really hate that that's ugly
that's ugly racial politics
fourth part of the story blm shows up
now i really hate that because they're
gonna go loot all the all the spaghetti
you know just like the the blm
arsonists and terrorists looted city
after city and burned down police
buildings and courthouses really hate
that
but then the final part of the story
blm is
opposing the mask mandate
citywide
i like that am i on the side of blm now
i guess in this regard i sort of am
politics makes for strange bedfellows
this to me is the most interesting part
of this whole story it's the it's the
only reason why this is news as far as
i'm concerned it's not because of the
typical racial politics that you always
hear about it's not that to me is the
least interesting part of the story
what's interesting here
is not the race aspect it's the covid
aspect
this kovid
kovidistan this new covidistan country
that we're all living in
is
realigning a lot of politics at least
temporarily and maybe it'll have more of
a permanent effect
the people who are opposed to the covid
public health dictatorship are not just
white male trump supporters
they're
black young black women
but we were told that's not possible
the people who are opposed to the mask
mandates
are
some radical leftists actually too
the people who do not like the way that
our government is being run
it's not it doesn't break down just on
party lines or even ideological lines
it's a little bit more
us versus them it's a little bit more
the people versus the ruling class it's
a little bit more the people who thought
we were living in a constitutional
republic versus
increasingly the oligarchy would you
know an oligarchy if you saw one
and so everyone when they're talking
about this carmine story and it's it is
going to crop up on tv you're only going
to hear people talking about the racial
aspect
don't take the bait don't fall for that
the interesting aspect
is what impelled these women
to
lose their temper and you know start you
know punching people in the first place
and what then impelled the racial
politics because that's the only way you
can talk about it because you're not
allowed to talk about the public health
dictatorship here's the proof of this
justin trudeau the prime minister of
canada is in hot water again
oh boy is he in trouble
oh justin what's he in trouble for is he
in trouble for a major corruption
scandal involving a construction company
called lavaland that took place just
three years ago
that where justin trudeau was actually
formally charged with an ethics
complaint this is the from canada's top
ethics watchdog is the first prime
minister in canada's history to have
this happen to him
just on paper the most corrupt prime
minister ever in the history of canada
no no it's not that
is it because he's persecuting
christians
and shutting down their churches no it's
not that is it because he's
like
canadian politicians for a very long
time permitting abortion up until the
moment of birth has some of the most
barbaric abortion laws in the entire
world
just pure infanticide no it's not that
it's because he um
oh he wore blackface once which we
already knew about
that's why he's that's the scandal
justin trudeau
who we know were blackface
now we have
another photo of him wearing blackface
from i think the same event
that's the big scandal
i do oh man i know i know this is going
to be this is going to get me in trouble
with all the left-wing groups out there
i don't i don't care that justin trudeau
work blackface i don't i i don't care at
all i don't care that jimmy fallon
or blackface neither does the left by
the way i don't care that ted danson
wore blackface neither does the left by
the way i don't care that joy behar wore
blackface neither does the left by the
way i don't care that megan kelly talked
about blackface once and the left really
cares if that's a big problem that's a
really that's you've got to lose your
career for that i don't care no one
actually cares
no nobody cares about blackface itself
people are using that
as a way to feign indignation
because
race is the only way that we can talk
about
sin and grace and justice and crime
anymore in the entire western world
but no one cares about the blackface
itself this is a real indictment of our
culture
that blackface is what people are
attacking justin trudeau for
on the on the long list of justin
trudeau's sins
blackface is somewhere around number
5326
okay it's not even close to the top
but i've said this before i may have
said it before on the show
the worst thing you can be called is a
racist
the only the only way we can talk about
transgressions of the moral order is in
terms of race and the reason for that is
we've adopted in many ways a materialist
view of the world so our view of the
world only runs skin deep now we deny
that god exists we deny that
a moral order exists we deny that
there's anything beyond the flesh in the
present and yet we still intuit that
some things are right and some things
are wrong so the only way that we can
discuss them is using the language of
skin as using the language of
physicality
this is why you heard around 9 11 you
heard people warning against anti-muslim
racism
as we pointed out then islam is not a
race islam is a religion so if you don't
like muslims or you object to islam
you are not doing so on the basis of
racism you're doing so on the basis of
your religious views you're doing so on
the basis of your philosophical views or
your sociological views but not racism
but that's the only way
that we can talk because we're stupid
because we've gotten extremely stupid in
this culture
and we do not possess the philosophical
or political sophistication
to debate these things is it any wonder
that increasingly we are living
in an oligarchy now speaking
of ethnically ambiguous governors we
have to move away from
the
melanated uh justin trudeau for a second
to talk about beto o'rourke
beto o'rourke sounds like a mexican
looks like an irishman beto o'rourke
you'll remember ran for what was the
first thing he's run for everything he
ran for senate against he was a
congressman kind of a backbencher
congressman then he ran for senate
against cruz and lost then he ran for
president and he got the spread baby
that guy vanity fair he was the one beto
is the one we've been waiting for and he
completely flopped he was just a joke
skateboarding punk in a whataburger
parking lot
who didn't go anywhere
and uh so then he lost and then he went
on this road trip where he pretended to
be like a beat poet and he wrote i'm
just trying to just trying to find
myself on the road well now he's back
not with a real job but he's back
running for governor again
according to axios
beta o'rourke is preparing to run for
governor of texas in 2022 with an
announcement expected later this year
texas political operatives tell axios
the reason i bring it up is not because
beto o'rourke is a serious person
but
you should not count your chickens
before they hatch
beto o'rourke is a joke of a person but
he is persistent
and persistence often pays off in
politics
look at senator john ossoff senator john
ossoff ran for congress in georgia he's
a democratic senator he ran for congress
in georgia hollywood flooded money in
there the whole democrat establishment
flooded money and he lost he was a joke
and then what happened he just ran again
later ran for senate he got an upgrade
right now he's now he's a senator
richard nixon lost the presidency in
1960
well
i i know we're not allowed to talk about
election fraud but
he officially lost the presidency in
1960 i know a lot of dead people voted
for kennedy so then he loses in 60. he
runs for governor of california in 1962
he loses that also his career is over
he's done
then he runs for president in 1968 and
he wins it's one of the greatest
political comebacks ever do not count
beto out the reason beto is running
right now is not because he thinks he's
gotten more popular or smarter or more
talented
the reason beto is running is because
we've changed our election systems and
beto is counting on the new election
systems
widespread mail in voting the
the reduction of election integrity
measures to push him over the finish
line he's also counting on the flood and
flood of illegal aliens who are pouring
over having an effect either immediately
or over time to give democrats an
advantage in texas do not count him out
he would not be running if he if he and
the democrats did not think he had some
chance of winning speaking of very bad
governors
this is a story that's not getting any
traction but it really should this is
one of the worst things that gavin
newsom has done in california it looks
like he's going to get away with it
in one of his first
actions since surviving his recall
election
governor newsom abolished single family
zoning in california newsome abolished
the suburbs is what that means
he greenlit a series of bills that will
increase the state's housing production
signs senate bill 9 into law
opens the door for the development of up
to four residential units on
single-family lots in california
the democrats have been pushing for this
for a very long time
because the democrats do very well in
the cities
they
do not do very well in the country and
the suburbs are the battleground
if you can effectively abolish the
suburbs if you can make the suburbs a
lot more urb
you the democrats will have a major and
probably permanent advantage
now i kind of like the suburbs i kind of
when i was a young man i wanted to be in
the city now that i'm an old man married
with a kid i like the suburbs are a
great place
where you can have the american dream
where you can have a house where you can
have maybe a little bit of property
where you can have a nice neighborhood
where it's not gangs running all over
and it's not
homeless and and needles and human feces
and it's not like you're living in san
francisco where you can have a nice
place to live for
relatively not a ton of money
that was the american dream
democrats have been trying to abolish
that for a long time because they don't
like america and they want to give us a
nightmare so
they've they've been pushing for this
and gavin newsom is one of the first
things he does not before the recall
election because he knows people are
going to hate it
but after the recall election all right
and gavin newsom he's not going to live
in some apartment building okay gavin
newsom is not going to live
in some duplex or
quadruplex where you know he's he's
living with a bunch he's going to get to
live in his nice house in his nice fancy
neighborhood and that's going to be fun
nancy pelosi is going to get to live in
her nice house in her nice fancy
neighborhood
and with her lovely american suburban
lifestyle dream but you're not
you don't get that because that's wrong
people need housing
how do you selfish deplorable you don't
even want
to build more housing right on your
backyard
it's not going to happen for the ruling
class
it's only going to happen for you
would you know an oligarchy
if you
saw one
you know
one of the signs
that we have lost control of our
government
is when the people that that are in
charge many of whom we put in charge or
at least it seems like we put them in
charge you know we go and we vote and
then they make appointments and then the
appointments make appointments and okay
so you've got this government
one of the signs that you've lost
control of your government is when the
ruling class rules by their whims by
their caprices
where it's
arbitrary
and
nowhere is that clearer
than in our new
covid policies the kovidistan country
that we're living in scott gottlieb
former commissioner of the fda
just went on face the nation
he was asked about this six foot rule
remember that so you got a mask up to
slow the spread you got to stand six
feet away from people
and then you got to get the vaccine and
even when you get the vaccine you still
got to stand away sometimes and masks
sometimes and it was all very unclear so
gottlieb was asked
where where did the six-foot rule come
from you know where it came from
ah
the six feet was arbitrary in and of
itself nobody knows where it came from
the initial recommendation that the cdc
brought to the white house and i talked
about this was 10 feet and a political
appointee in the white house said we
can't recommend 10 feet nobody can
measure 10 feet it's inoperable society
will shut down so the compromise was
around six feet now imagine if that
detail had leaked out everyone would
have said this is the white house
politically interfering with the cdc's
judgment the cdc said ten feet it should
be ten feet but ten feet was no more
right than six feet and ultimately
became three feet but when it became
three feet
the the basis for the cdc's decision to
ultimately revise it from six to three
feet was a study that they had conducted
the prior fall so they changed it in the
spring
so
he goes on it's worth listening to the
whole interview because gottlieb really
gives you a peek behind the curtains i
always i always sort of liked gottlieb
he was he was the trump fda commissioner
and uh you know
i wish trump had handled kovid better he
was really up against the wall i don't
think there's any republican who would
have handled kovid
better but you do wish there was a guy
who just said like no we're not doing
this we're just not going to lock down
you don't get 15 days you don't get
anything
we're just going to keep the country
open and deal with it
it was
almost certainly impossible
politically and
otherwise but
at least now they're kind of opening the
curtain on this and so what gottlieb
says is the six foot recommendation no
one has any idea where it came from but
then he goes on he says the original
recommendation was 10 feet that was from
the cdc
so you're gonna hear people tell you
well yeah six feet was arbitrary but
really it should have been 10 and they
just said politically you couldn't do it
except that the 10 feet was wrong too
it was just
i don't know
then it became
three feet
three feet that's okay and now okay the
compromise is this and that what is the
compromise i thought we were talking
about science
we're just talking about the
incompetent
but ironclad rule
of a ruling class
and they're just going to keep it up by
the way they're just kidding we can i
can talk until i'm blue in the face
say look it was arbitrary look the masks
look the distance look that
doesn't matter
they're going to keep it up they're not
going to abide by the policies
themselves especially if they're feeling
the spirit
but they are going to force you to abide
by all of these policies the left is
very persistent you know there there are
bands
in certain parts of this country now on
critical race theory in schools that's
great i love that i think we got to kick
it out of schools there's three views on
this there's the leftist view which is
indoctrinate kids into critical race
theory there's the libertarian view
which is you know just do whatever do
whatever you want and it's kind of up to
you and i don't want to impose my views
on you and it's a free marketplace of
ideas right and then there's the
conservative view which is no this stuff
is poison it undermines students
education kick it out and fire the
teachers who push it
so there's an iowa teacher
who is very frustrated by the crt ban
and now she's bragging about the ways
that she circumvents it
i said but we also need to take a look
at hf-802 and i literally put the law in
front of them gave them access to it
with a link and i said and i need to
just let you know there are now concepts
that is illegal for me to teach you
about
according to the state of iowa and we
went through um they used to be called
defined concept or divisive concepts now
they're called defined concepts in our
law um so i went through those ten
defined concepts with them um so that
they could see what the law was and they
immediately by the time i think we're on
the second or third one they're like but
is it illegal for me to ask questions
can i i was like
this is only for me you can ask as many
questions as you like and then i took
them to the part of the law that said um
this law doesn't prohibit me from
answering questions
i said so if there's any question that
you have about these defined concepts
you can ask them and then i can answer
them
so i said so let's just take another
minute
what questions do you have that you want
me to build this course around and take
some time to answer and the questions
after going through hf 802 were so much
more pointed like one of them straight
up was a sticky note that says is the
united states systemically racist
and i was like well that would be a
fascinating conversation but now we can
have because you've asked
well wow isn't she clever is it she's so
clever she's gonna because the the law
like the
the people let me just i'll take you
through she probably hasn't seen
schoolhouse rock in a while the people
voted for their representatives and the
people fund the government including the
public schools and pay that woman's
salary and then the people said you know
we don't want you teaching our kids that
white people are horrible and racist and
irredeemable we don't we don't think
that's good we don't think it's true
and we don't think it's good to teach a
kid that and we think you're a psycho
and we don't want you doing that so they
pass a law through their
constitutional order
and then this teacher says thank you
thank you for that salary that's good
thank you for your that paycheck i'm
gonna put that over here and you know i
love our democracy our democracy is so
great and now i'm gonna completely
disregard the law
and i'm going to continue to teach kids
that white people are evil and america's
a terrible place she just admits it
there she goes is america systemically
racist well
you know i'm the law says i'm not
allowed to tell you that it is but
that's an interesting question
and since you asked since i impelled you
to ask that question no i'm going to
tell you it's terrible america's
terrible and white people are evil and
everything's and you're the worst
and we all need to become like haiti and
that's why we need to let the hate all
the haitians into america is that am i
following that and you've got to mask up
unless you're feeling the spirit if you
are a democrat mayor or a hollywood
celebrity but not you because you the
people are evil and i don't care what
you tell me to do and i don't care what
laws you pass
i am not beholden to your laws
would you know an oligarchy if you saw
one i'm michael nelson's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show